well listen masturbation is in the news
um
this week not that i have to tell you i
i feel bad about
constantly making fun of jeffrey two but
you know when you when you do what he
did you know people are gonna make fun
especially comedians okay uh and i just
say that the name
tubin to me it really lends itself
it's like you know because i and i think
it will probably be a word in itself
in the future meaning to masturbate
during a zoom meeting
he as in that meeting was so boring i
was tubing the whole time
you know so
so i realized you know every year in the
dictionary they put out like the
list of new words that are neoligism
they call it new words that come into
the language and with this year in covid
there's going to be a whole list that
are just related to pandemic living
like tubin and we found some of the
other ones like the practice of bumping
elbows instead of shaking hands is funny
boning
you see that's what shoppers experience
when they actually
find clorox wipes is called a storgasm
[Laughter]
uh someone during a coveted test who
says let me do it myself and gets the
q-tip stuck in his nose
that's a nostril dumbass that's a
that's a new one
oh getting airlifted to a hospital for
treatment unavailable to the public
that's called wealthcare
uh when you're scared to even think
about how long you've been wearing the
same underwear
those are frighty whities
and when a wife gets so drunk on her
zoom happy hour she even has sex with
her husband that's a
chardon lay okay
you